أهلا بكم من جديد ، أفرجت إيران عن مواطن لبناني
كان لديه أيضًا إقامة دائمة في الولايات المتحدة
بعد احتجازه لمدة
أربع سنوات.  تم القبض على إيكا في عام 2015
وإدانته بتهمة التجسس
لحكومات أجنبية قال القضاء الإيراني
إن الإفراج كان اقتباسًا من عملية قضائية
دون أي مواقف سياسية
في وقت سابق. لقد تحدثت إلى
وزير الخارجية اللبناني جبران
باسيلي وسألته عن سبب حصول السيد.
تم الإفراج عن زاكا مؤخرًا ، كتبت خطابًا
إلى وزير الخارجية أطلب فيه العفو
عنه بسبب عطلة رمضان
، وطلب رئيس
الجمهورية الجنرال ميشلان من
الرئيس روحاني إطلاق سراحه ، وعلى
هذا النحو تم إبلاغنا بأن طلبنا
قد تم قبوله و  لقد تم
تسليمه الآن إلى القصر الرئاسي لرئيسنا ،
ما
مغزى توقيت الإفراج ، هل
تعتقد أنني لا أعرف ما إذا كانت هناك
علاقة سياسية بالضرورة
بالتوتر الجاري ولكن إذا كان هناك
تفسير واحد فقط فهو كذلك  علامة على
الإيجابية ، هل تعتقد أنها يمكن أن تكون
رسالة إلى الولايات المتحدة لأنه كان حقًا للولايات المتحدة
، يمكن أن تكون هناك ضرورة
لعدم وجود توتر يؤدي إلى صراع أو
أن الله يحرم الحرب ويمكننا اتباع
مسار مختلف  للحوار ما مدى
قلقك من تصعيد
التوترات بين إيران والولايات المتحدة
بصراحة لست قلقا من مثل هذا
التصعيد لأنه لا أحد يستطيع أن يتحمل
ثمن الحرب سيتضرر كلا الجانبين
بشدة وستعاني المنطقة
كثيرا لذا سيخرج المزيد من التطرف
والإرهاب من هذا لذا
لا أعتقد  أن العالم بحاجة إلى هذا
الآن نحن بحاجة للسعي إلى الاعتدال.